[Musique]
et donc je voudrais plus vieilles salles
de cinéma de vierzon qui s'appelait le
simple et le carillon à l'époque elle
est ouverte en 1926 avec un film muet et
films et émeut l'époque de cinéma
parlant n'était pas encore inventé le
film s'appelait simone et il a tenu
l'affiché pendant plus d'un mois à
l'époque et en faisant salle comble tous
les jours tous les jours entre les
journal il était actif jusque dans les
années je continuerai dû fermer en 96
il a terminé en cinéma films de karaté
fume pour notre lâcheté dans les années
2000 quand j'ai vu qu'il était resté
dans son jus j'ai décidé d'essayer de
sauver d'une part pour sauver le
patrimoine un peu de la ville de vierzon
et d'autre part pour pouvoir avoir un
lieu où on magasine et tout mon matériel
que je collectionnais depuis des années
puisque l'ancien ancien projectionniste
à chaque fois que les cinémas surtout
ceux de la ville de bourges fermé je
récupérer un maximum de matériel je
possède à peu près 300 projecteurs j'ai
jamais compté exactement de tous les
formats dont la dans la plupart sont
toujours en état de la technique 1912
format 28 mm mes copains mes amis me
disent c'est à danseuse
effectivement c'est ma danseuse elle me
coûte assez cher d'ailleurs mais par
contre ne m'a jamais déçu
quand j'avais 4 ans en 1949 je suis mon
père m'a emmené voir un film qui
s'appelait le roi pandore avec avec
bourvil dans le plus grand cinéma de
bourges le grand panel qu'il y avait
1200 places et puis bah quand j'ai vu
cette image apparaître sur l'écran et où
j'ai voulu savoir exactement comment ça
marchait d'ailleurs je regardais dans le
fond de la salle ce pinceau lumineux qui
sortait d'un hublot et en sortant du
cinéma
nous sommes passés par des sorties de
secours et il y avait une porte qui
était ouverte et j'ai aperçu ces
projecteurs ces groupes projecteurs noir
énorme qui s'était des supers simplex à
l'époque pour un enfant de 4 ans dans
l'impression de se trouver on fasse une
locomotive à vapeur et l'opérateur qui
étaient là à bien mon père mais si
l'enfant veut regarder comment ça marche
et m'a pris dans ses bras et j'ai monté
deux ou trois marchés j'ai vu si les
appareils étaient énormes qui m'ont
impressionné les jeunes là je vois
comment ça marche
j'aurais jamais cru qu'un jour j'aurai
travaillé dans le cinéma et que
j'aimerais même réussi à récupérer lors
de sa fermeture ces fameux appareil que
j'ai réinstallé qui fonctionne toujours
[Musique]
roland